[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute packe ich eine ramadan torte also
für asamoah st
für das fest und ich habe mir echte kopf
darüber zerbrochen was ich denn wohl
machen werde
das letzte mal habe ich noch von hand
orte gemacht mit so einem orientalischen
muster und die waffe echt cool gerne das
video anschauen
ja mit pistaziengrün ich glaube dahin
hatte ich noch mit drin kummer konnte
kommt schon besucht und dieses mal habe
ich mir vorgestellt machen bei einer
mondsichel es ist eine mond form ja
warum mord warum sally weil der mond den
menschen den weg zeigt denn im
islamischen kalender da gibt's ja nur
elf monate und deswegen ist der ramadan
monats immer zehn tage früher weil er
einfach nicht nach dem neuen
kalenderjahr geht es nach mond genau und
man schaut eben wenn die mondsichel zu
sehen ist dann fängt der amateur monat
an
und deswegen habe ich mir gedacht komm
das ist das symbol des islams und
deswegen machen wir eine mondsichel
trotte ich bin ja fast aufgeregt denn
ich habe es ja so noch nie gemacht und
wir schauen jetzt einfach mal wie es
funktioniert und ich habe mir gedacht
wir machen eine naked torte als eine
nackte torte mit einem eps boden spielt
torte obendrauf ok kennst du schon vom
geschmack schmeckt richtig lag und
komisch aber es schmeckt echt ganze welt
bin ich überrascht seine spinat oder
hast du in deinen türkischen buch
übrigens gemacht er habe das ein
bisschen anders gemacht aber ich glaube
es wird richtig lecker und jetzt starten
wir einfach mal direkt mit dem man sich
cool findet steht schon einfach da bist
du zu machen sauber karriere für den
mürbeteig verwende ich 240 gramm kalte
butter 120 gramm butter zucker etwas
salz vanille extrakt und 1 1 380 gramm
mehl und 120 gramm gemahlene mandeln der
mürbeteig mit der zeit gestellt wie beim
einem letter cache also zuerst kommt
jetzt die butter in der rührschüssel und
wird gemeinsam mit puderzucker vanille
extrakt um salz berührt
jetzt kommt hier noch dazu
und dann auch schon die trockenen
zutaten also mail und mandeln
jetzt nehme ich den teil von formeln zu
einer kugel
es geht am besten mit den händen
es gebe ich ihnen in der form
reindrücken slug damit es schneller
abkühlt decken auch noch ab und stellen
für eine stunde kühl und in der
zwischenzeit machen wir schon mal den
spinat teig für den spinat kuchen
verwende ich 400 gramm spinat 100
milliliter sahne für 200 gramm zucker
eine prise salz sind und tonkabohne
etwas vanille extrakt 300 gramm mehl 2
teelöffel backpulver und 150 gramm
flüssige butter
den spinat habe ich schon gewaschen und
den gebe ich jetzt tropfnass in einem
topf das siedelt nach ganz viel aus aber
es jetzt gleich ganz wenig glaubt es mir
einfach okay es passt nicht aber das ist
fast nicht gemacht hätte wieder so lange
gekocht bis er zusammen fährt und fast
keine flüssigkeit mehr im topf passt
[Musik]
während der spinat noch ein kocht kann
ich schon mal die eier hierfür rühren
und zwar komme es die eier in eine
rührschüssel dann der zucker manila
extrakt
und hier habe ich noch salz und die
tonkabohne die tonkabohne ist ein ganz
ganz tolles gehört könnt ihr auf jeden
fall mal ausprobieren die muss gerieben
werden und man darf auch nicht zu viel
davon nehmen
das riecht schon richtig lecker und
jetzt die eier zucker masse einfach für
etwa zehn minuten ungefähr schaumig
verrühren
[Musik]
das spiel ist jetzt richtig schön
eingekocht also man sieht auch wenn ich
drücke es kommt fast keine flüssigkeit
mehr raus und genauso brauchen wir ihn
jetzt gebe ich das ganze in einen mixer
da kommt die sahne dazu und dann wird's
püriert durch die sahne kühler spinat
natürlich ein bisschen ab und ich
bekomme auch nicht wenige konsistent
[Musik]
das püree stelle ich fritz zur seite
denn jetzt wird die backform gerichtet
jetzt könnt ihr entweder den teig gleich
in einem backblech backen und später die
form eurer wahl zu schneiden oder ihr
bad direkt so dass man gleich ein
halbmond hat das heißt ich habe jetzt
ein backblech die dauer back folie es
nämlich zwei torten ringe den einen
stelle ich jetzt auf 30 cm 1
und jetzt nehme ich einen zweiten dann
nämlich jetzt man fest stehenden weil
der einfach keinen klub hat natürlich
könnt ihr auf den mitglied nehmen aber
der bagdad an so ein bisschen betreiben
daher ist ohne kleber ziel besser und
dann fick sehe ich das ganze mit den
zwei edelstahl haarklammern die habe ich
immer in der küche findet sich nicht für
die haare
folglich nur betonen und dann habe ich
jetzt hier im prinzip schon diese schöne
form
jetzt geht so ein tag weiter die eier
creme ist jetzt super cremig richtig
schön dickflüssig das sieht man auch und
es ist auch ganz wichtig damit der teig
einfach nicht so flüssig wird und da
kommt jetzt wie spinat mit rein weiß es
klingt komisch aber es ist wirklich sehr
lecker spinat orte ist richtig lecker
das irgendwie bekomme ich jetzt los doch
frank spinath mit kartoffeln und
spiegelei ich weiß nicht warum dann ganz
kurz unterrühren
den rest mache ich dann mit schneebesen
[Musik]
hier führe ich jetzt das backpulver mit
dem mehl so verbindet sich gut und
verteilt sie schön im teig die zutaten
werden dann hinein gesiebt und gemeinsam
mit der flüssigen butter untergehoben
[Musik]
und so kommt der teig ist in die selbst
gebastelte mondsichel wurde die saison
nicht zu flüssig es kommt einfach daher
dass ich die eier zucker machst du
wirklich sehr sehr lange schaumig rühren
und auch schön bis in die ecken reihen
und während dieser teig gebacken wird
für den mürbeteig der mürbeteig ist
schon kalt und jetzt wieder ausgerollt
dafür nämlich ein bisschen mehl und kann
ihnen jetzt auch erstmal noch mal kurz
durchkneten
und jetzt auf 5 mm stärke ausrollen und
geht am besten wenn ihr teilzunehmen und
die nebendran legt
[Musik]
ich nehme dann immer gerne palette dann
ein bisschen mehl
man könnte damit der fall des mehls
unterschrieben und dann löst sich dabei
auch ganz gut und klebt nicht fest
[Musik]
jetzt legen hier ein backpapier drauf
dann einen topplatz umstürzen auch auf
die andere seite
jetzt vorsichtig auf den kopf drehen
am besten schneiden
und ich habe jetzt noch einen zweiten
tortenring da hat jetzt die gleiche
größe wie der kuchen der gerade noch im
ofen ist ihr könnt dabei euch natürlich
auch vorher einfach eine schablone
machen jetzt vorsichtig ausstechen immer
der große kreis und stand der kleine nun
jetzt hier am rand oder ansetzen
entferne ich den überschüssigen teig den
rolle ich jetzt einfach wieder zusammen
zu einer kugel stehling kühl und kann
daraus dann noch kekse backen wenn ich
lust ab oder mit zwei gebäuden und bevor
date gebacken wird muss auch ins
gefrierfach oder in den kühlschrank für
mindestens eine stunde damit das schön
kalt ist und beim backen die form
einfach nicht verliert also jetzt kurz
kühl und danach dann packen
nach dem abkühlen kann der spinat eick
jetzt ganz vorsichtig aus der backform
gelöst werden und dafür nehme ich einen
tortenring messer
[Musik]
der wird es jetzt richtig schön kalt und
der wird jetzt auch gepackt worden
während dem überzeugen noch im ofen ist
kann ich schon mal die dicke vorbereiten
der eine tag ist ja schon fertig und ich
habe jetzt hier eine kleinere schablone
zubereitet vorbereitet die einfach
kleiner ist als hier oben damit ich das
ganze hier aus modelle schokolade formen
kann
und ich habe ich jetzt 200 gramm weiße
modell schokolade bereits weiß geknetet
und es reicht normalerweise auch wird
diese menge aus also am besten schon in
die form so ein bisschen rollen und dann
einfach ausschneiden trotten retter da
kommt ein bisschen becker stärke drauf
die mutter der schokolade und hier
darauf kann ich dann schön
zurechtschneiden und ein bisschen
antrocknen lassen
[Musik]
so jetzt hab ich das ganze schön
ausgeschnitten und las ist aber noch mit
der vorlage einfach ein bisschen
trocknen die kuchen böden abkühlen und
dann habe ich gleich weiter für die
creme verwende ich 500 milliliter sahne
250 gramm mascarpone 150 km frischkäse
etwas vanille extrakt 150 gramm
puderzucker und etwas sonderbar nämlich
zuerst die mascarpone und die kommt hier
direkt in der schüssel hinein nicht
obendrauf und die wir jetzt ganz kurz
cremig gerührt
jetzt kann ich schon langsam die sahne
zufügen und so verbindet sich dann auch
alles schön
was kaputt setzt sich gerne mal am rand
fest aber dann einfach kurz im teig
schaber durch und damit den rest seiner
dazu
hier kommt jetzt auch der frischkäse mit
rein ihr könnt natürlich auch die
mascarpone ersetzen durch frischkäse
denn verstehe so durch mascarpone sowie
ihr das gerne mögen was ihr am liebsten
es jetzt noch etwas vanille extrakt
jetzt eine vanillecreme zitronenschale
afrika auf möglich aber ich möchte es
gerne bei der vanille belassen
dann bruder zucker mit rein und
sommerbad und dann die creme steif
schlagen
krems stelle ich jetzt ganz kurz kühl
und kann schon mal den tortenboden
durchschneiden
den abgekühlten tortenboden schneide ich
jetzt mit einer torte säge durch ganz
vorsichtig ihr könnt ja entweder einmal
durchschneiden zur auf zwei bühnen
entstehen die etwas dicker sind oder
zweimal so dass drei bilden entstehen
ich probiere mit drei aber ganz
vorsichtig vor allem an der spitze vorne
[Musik]
also wer ganz mutig ist schmal wird
einfach vier böden und wer eine flache
torte wird es macht einfach die hälfte
vom rezept perfekt jetzt nehme ich den
abgekühlten mürbeteig und da streiche
ich jetzt noch mal gerade drauf was ganz
gut passen würde während zeigen
marmelade zum beispiel oder einfach eine
marmelade eure wahl
jetzt kann ich hier den ersten boden
einfach aufsetzen
hier der mitte habe ich ein bisschen was
weggeschnitten denn das standen bislang
über ist aber nicht schlimm
das kann man über naschen und jetzt habe
ich die creme in zwei schritten gefüllt
einmal mit großer stern thüle also hier
und einmal mit einer kleinen stern könne
hier
und zwar deswegen wir vorne bei der
spitze braucht nimmt die kleine stern
thüle und es wird ja ein naked bike also
man sieht von außen dann den teig und
auch die creme und daher jetzt beim
drauf spritzen einfach auf profi
[Musik]
was hier außen stritt sich einfach mit
der kleinen spritztour
dieses muster
[Musik]
das hat jetzt auch eine drehleiter war
für mich einfach
und ihnen damit schneller geht mit der
großen töne auffüllen
[Musik]
jetzt den nächsten boden nehmen und
vorsichtig draufsetzen
[Musik]
so wird jetzt die komplette torte
gefüllt wer möchte kann natürlich auch
noch früchte reinlegen erdbeeren zum
beispiel aber ich denke dass man einfach
ganz am ende
[Musik]
ich lasse meine torte so drei bereichen
wir auf jeden fall aus den anderen
können wir aufheben und noch etwas
anderes zaubern
der kuchen oder die torte kommt jetzt in
den kühlschrank und dann kann ich mit
dem ich schon mal um die deko kümmern
[Musik]
für die torte bastle ich jetzt noch eine
tortenplatte dafür nämlich ein eckiges
skateboard und überdies mit blauem von
dort ich habe ich jetzt 46 und blauen
von bauer bereits weiß geknetet und dünn
ausgerollt jetzt bestreite ich das
skateboard mit essbarem kleber lege denn
von dort rüber streichen glatt und
schneidet dann die überreste weg das
skateboard kann jetzt ein bisschen
antrocknen und ich fühle mich jetzt um
die mondsichel hier verwende ich jetzt
für die dekoration diese zucker schrift
und zwar in schwarz-weiß gold und rot
die habe ich vorher jetzt ein bisschen
weich geknetet zum üben mit also zum
schreiben üben kann einfach einen teller
nehmen und dann hier einfach ein
bisschen was schreiben oder zur not auch
noch einen pinsel zu helfen
[Musik]
ich wollte jetzt hier eigentlich auf tür
geschrieben als er damals an beidem an
das kurze aber ist ein bisschen zu lang
also manchmal ramadan karim das ist auch
international bedeutet das gleiche und
wünscht einfach ein
[Musik]
die torten unterlage war schön
angetrocknet hier habe ich jetzt mit
etwas puder fahre in blau und schwarz
einfach das ganze ein bisschen
abgepuffert jetzt kommen noch sterne
drauf und dafür nehme ich jetzt goldene
strafbare natürliche lebensmittelfarbe
die spüre ich jetzt in den deckel rein
so bekomme ich die goldfarbe schön
zusammen in einen deckel jetzt nämlich
einen dünnen pinsel und mache zu tun
ich hab eigentlich nur gemacht weil es
spaß macht kurz trocknen lassen
jetzt wird die torte freilich dekoriert
ich nehme jetzt die kleine töne und
spritzt jetzt die creme auf die
oberfläche
[Musik]
es hat gereicht aber ich habe ja auch
schon was ausprobiert hier auch ein
teller deswegen das war jetzt bei
gefehlt hat aber es hat gereicht genau
richtig ich nehme jetzt dieses gold
spray was ich eben schon verwendet habe
die kann man nämlich auch auf cremes
sprühen jetzt nur aufpassen dass er
nicht herankommt und dann die creme
damit ein spiel
[Musik]
sind dadurch wird die creme einfach ein
bisschen edler
[Musik]
so gefällt sie mir sehr gut und vor
allem hat man wirklich eine richtig
schöne symbolische bedeutung da wir
machen kurz unsere fotos und dann machen
wir es den anschnitt
[Musik]
kurze info murat während dem bug prozess
nicht da ja einmal arbeiten ich war
nämlich auch nicht wie sie aussieht nein
ich habe seinen kühlschrank
ich warte baustelle auge zu und ist nur
cool das mal klassisch und ich denke
auch ist ja sehr sehr viele nachmachen
ja bin ich echt cool das letzte mal bei
von dann haben viele gesagt ja schöne
torte aber er macht schon mehr von land
und diesmal haben deswegen eine spinat
orte naked und obendrauf dem schriftzug
da habe ich jetzt den arabischen
schriftzug genommen weil der türkische
zu lang ist zweimal seien weiter nur im
ok weil sie zwei wochen wir gehen immer
gefragt warum dies nicht auch typisch
geschrieben hat habe ich doch schon
erklärt da stand nicht da ja unsere sie
die theater aus wie gefällt sie dierkow
und ehrliche meinung ich muss echt schön
also eigentlich wollte noch früchte mit
drauf machen aber es wird zu viel
gewesen genau
franz alt und wisse nicht ob ich
wirklich genial leute richtig klar sind
dadurch nicht gesund aber grün das
problem ja ich habe jetzt eigentlich
nach statiker wahlgeschenke erschrecken
und sagen es ist das fazit klingt jetzt
einfach die spitze weg okay nun nummer
so zur info ich weiß ist gerade aus der
türkei in der türkei wird grad gibt es
keinen streik und wie gesagt dass mit
pistazien ich gerade die türkei ein
riesenthema
und zwar streiten die ganzen bäckereien
die machen nichts mit pistazien mit
pistazien preis so in die höhe
geschossen ist und hat nichts mit
pistazien ja das ist echt sondern echt
krass deswegen habe ich jetzt auch echt
bewusst auf pizza sind verzichtet obwohl
sehr geschmack nicht aufpassen würden ja
ein kleines stück über fast und bis
videos anschaut
aber ich würde zum anrichten würde ich
glaube ich schon noch ein paar früchte
dazu lägen also so erdbeeren zeigen
wären toll aber dreimal die jahreszeit
gerade nicht probiert er probiert
aber ich habe die creme windows gesehen
hat gold eingespielt
helmut kohl oder murat schmeckt man den
spinat raus die modelle schokolade
gegessen ich möchte ja auch richtig
lecker leute modellierter ist richtig
lecker steigt nach weiter vorlage bei
der iss bringen so die können ja auch
sahne legen sondern weil ich ja auch auf
seine deswegen bei fondant auflagen
nicht rückschnitt nicht ganz ganz leger
also bitte erst mal nur das wir
gebraucht wir haben vorgedreht nicht
dass jetzt fragt warum ich esse werde
fast der boden dort ist er noch sehr
frisch aber der boden wird die torte am
tag vorher macht wird sie auch noch
schön war also wird der boden schön war
ich dann kann man es ob es hat
durchschneiden und man kann auch die
torte gern schon am tag vorher zu
bereiten
die modelle schokolade würde ich
trotzdem erst so am nächsten tag drauf
legen damit sie nicht doch nicht durch
war ich war einfach zur sicherheit ja
und ansonsten finde ich echt cool ist
gefällt mir dass die torte schmeckt und
ich find's schön man kann schön kleine
stücke herr unterscheiden weil beim
ramadan ist aber uns so also ich weiss
an weihnachten ist es so bei vielen
familien dafür zu hause bleiben und im
kleinen kreis feiern einfach die zeit so
verbringen
bei uns ist es aber beim ramadan immer
so da besucht man einfach immer die
älteren und man bekommt halt auch viel
besuch deswegen ist ja immer schön wenn
man was macht sowie back war zum
beispiel was man dann in kleinen
portionen viel anbieten kann und hier
bei der torte kann man auch einfach
kleine feine scheiben und bekommen es
auch mehr besucher genau ja auch wenn
man nicht da haben wohl nicht kommen
trotzdem her was du deine eltern dich
machen auszukommen hallodri sport
seine mama wohnt ja leider in der türkei
aber also wir wünschen euch einen
schönen ramadan weiter man ist eine
badehose für die türken halle durch und
will wie alle anderen aktivisten nicht
fasten die kündigt russin nachmachen
andere die chance genau weißt die form
echt cool findet auch mal so viel torte
also viel spaß beim nachhaken wird eine
schöne zeit und bis zum nächsten wahlen
haben wir das video so in die länge
gezogen
[Musik]